bonjour à toutes et à tous bonne semaine
d'ores et déjà et bienvenue dans cet
autre cas dit ce matin avec manuela
clarmont désir bonjour d'engins et ses
carnets d'un jour at on indiqué vous
êtes député vous êtes devenu député de
la martinique en 2018 en raison de la
démission de bruno nestor azérot dont
vous étiez la suppléante
vous êtes devenue la deuxième femme à
député martiniquaise josette manin vous
êtes membre de la délégation aux
outre-mer à l'assemblée nationale
française
et puis c'est vrai que c'est moins connu
il faut le préciser vous êtes secrétaire
à la commission défense et des forces
armées
alors avant d'entamer d'entrer dans le
vif du sujet dit nous en quoi ça a son
importance de faire partie d'être
membres mêmes secrétaire de cette
commission l'assemblée nationale alors
c'est vrai que là on va dire défense on
se sent loin un peu la martinique de
cette commission mais je veux juste
rappeler que c'est grâce à ma
contribution à mes interventions au sein
de cette commission que nous avons pu
récupérer martinique deux patrouilleurs
d'équipements pour intervenir notamment
en mer sur la question sécuritaire mais
également au niveau de la coopération en
cas de risque majeur en cas de deux on
va dire de contrôle aussi des trafics
exact est d'ailleurs l'une des batailles
que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
équiper de caméras de radars les côtes
de la martinique c'est en bonne voie
voilà ceci précisé donc nous allons nous
préciser que nous entamons avec vous une
série d'entretiens avec les différents
parlementaires du territoire nous avons
commencé la semaine dernière avec la
sénatrice catherine conconne et nous
poursuivons donc avec vous aujourd'hui
alors évidemment je vous fait réagir à
la manifestation pour que la justice
passe finalement dans le dossier de l'
usage dérogatoire de la chlordécone en
guadeloupe et en martinique
singulièrement chez nous samedi il y a
eu des milliers de personnes pas loin de
dix mille certains estiment même que ils
ont été un peu plus nombreux
réunis réunis pour manifester pour
protester assez pacifiquement finalement
c'est les messages sont passés mais n'y
a pas eu d'incident qu'en pensez vous
alors j'étais présentait effectivement
j'étais assez satisfaite et je pense que
tout le monde a pu voir la masse et la
population qui a aussi répondu à cet
appel parce que je crois que nous sommes
tous concernés
nous sommes tous touchés très sensible à
la question on va dire au scandale dans
la chlordécone
mais aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'à
un nouveau scandale qui ce qui s'annonce
c'est on va dire ce manque de justice
vis-à-vis du traitement de ce dossier
donc évidemment nous sommes
tous les parlementaires tous les élus
eux
attaché à ce que la question du
chlordécone de la cour d'école ou du
corps défendant fonction de soi soit on
va dire statut et un constat tu as
dessus de manière à ce que non seulement
les personnes curité les victimes
puissent être dès demain dédommager
indemnisés que leurs préoccupations
notamment sur leur santé soit vraiment
prise en compte et et la question de la
reconnaissance aussi comme maladie
professionnelle
on va dire l'impact de la chlordécone
sur sur les oubliés sur les personnes
qui ont eu un a touché à intervenir sur
ces produits pour nous et moi en tout
cas pour moi est très importante alors
donc je soutiens et et vraiment je suis
solidaire de sept de ses démarches et
vous avez précisé que vous y étiez
samedi cet aspect de l'indemnisation
elle est on va en parler on va en dire
quelques mots
elle est comprise dans le plan dans les
plan chlordécone est celui qui qui vient
d'être officialisée la semaine dernière
et qui est dans les quintés voilà le
plan chlordécone 4 et d'ailleurs on
rappelle que la déclinaison
martiniquaise va être présenté cette
semaine par la préfecture tout cela est
compris dépollution des sols etc
mais là ça va un peu plus loin la
population de manière de plus en plus
unitaire et peut-être massive réclame
que la justice ne sera pas faite
non mais cet aspect est important
vous en tant que député que comptez-vous
faire avec d'ailleurs est ce que là il
faut une démarche unitaire de l'ensemble
des parlementaires selon vous que
comptez-vous faire quant à ce qui
apparaît quand même comme une question
d'un recul de l'état de droit dans cette
affaire
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya là il ya le
temps d'ajouter s'il ya le temps du
politique
et il ya le temps de la population et je
crois que nous avons trois éléments qui
sont essentiels bon que justement on
puisse faire fléchir je pense qu'étant
dans cette tendance qui qui a l'air de
de se profiler est ce que ça pourrait
passer par par exemple l'imposition de
modification de la loi parce que quand
on nous dit que nous y aurait
prescription et donc que ça pourrait
entraîner un non lieu
beaucoup de martiniquaise de
martiniquais ne peuvent l'entendre
moi je pense que la question de la
prescription effectivement nous pouvons
et nous en avons déjà discuté d'ailleurs
entre parlementaires entre notamment
d'entente entre députés
nous avons pour projet de proposer une
proposition de loi mais là aussi c'est
pas le même c'est pas le même timing
nous avons un timing est beaucoup plus
serré il a aujourd'hui donc il faut
vraiment une
une démarche unitaire pour pour on va
dire influencé cette décision qui ce
temps tout en préparant justement ce
projet de loi pour que la question de la
prescription ne puisse pas être être et
d'ailleurs c'est une démarche aussi qu'a
entrepris la guadeloupe discussion que
j'ai eue avec notamment le député servat
c'est à l'image un peu de ce qui s'est
passé récemment sur les violences
les violences
le tout fait aux enfants en français
serait donc on peut peut-être défaire la
loi parce que la justice
ll est dans son cadre je pense vraiment
y aller foldé faire mais il faut faire
attention une affaire éminemment
politique
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
remonter au plus haut niveau de
l'agresseur et bien sûr bien sûr et
c'est ça l'objectif c'est cela aussi le
rôle d'un parlementaire c'est de
dépasser
on va bien le le périmètre local et
d'aller vers vers le national mais
encore une fois je parle d'une
solidarité martinique guadeloupe pour
que nous puissions avant une force
beaucoup plus un impact beaucoup plus
fort sur cette question le plan
chlordécone 4 on ya fait allusion c'est
comment vous le trouvez à la maquette
c'est pas vraiment à la hauteur même bon
évidemment il faut il faut saluer qui a
une à spec tiens on va dire qu'ils qui
est nouveau c'est la question de la
recherche
même si je considère que c'est toujours
insuffisant mais voilà donc vous avez
compris que je reste un peu il faut
mieux faire encore mal les suite des
intempéries qui dit a eu à sainte-marie
au moment des faits on vous avez vu mais
effectivement sur le terrain vous
continuez à suivre cette affaire
finalement vous maintient alors c'est
vrai je dis je
chacun à son niveau d'intervention je ne
peux pas interférer ni celui des
affaires communales ni
non je vais pas précisé me rappelle que
évidemment vous avez été élu dans la
circonscription du nord
et c'est vrai que ma circonscription a
été particulièrement touché 7 maggie
marigot et d'autres d'autres communes un
peu un peu moins fortement est
d'ailleurs très tôt j'ai rencontré
dessiner ce qu'est ce que j'ai conseillé
très rapidement de se constituer en
association en collectif parce que lui
dit partir chacun de son côté
ça va être plus difficile que si vous
êtes encore une fois la démarche
solidaire groupés et c'est ce qu'ils ont
réalisé je crois que ça a été une
première démarche de ce2 de se regrouper
pour pouvoir faire entendre leur voix
et puis évidemment la question de la
reconnaissance de catastrophe naturelle
pour un mouvement et glissements de
terrain nous engager sur la durée vous
irez jusqu'au bout oui tous la mairie
alors je suis toujours en contact avec
justement c'est
c'est les sinistrés il ya une démarche
qui est très intéressante qui qui a été
mise en place après la visite du
ministre
le corps nul ministre du commerce qui
est le copil suivi comité des otages qui
suis un petit peu les dossiers au cas
par cas et il avait indiqué ainsi ni ce
qu'est une solution et je crois qu'ils
sont dans cette démarche a mis du temps
parce que il faut évidemment tous les
organismes
ça prend plus de temps pour la
martinique je sais pas si c'est les 8000
kilomètres que dans certaines régions
c'est une semaine les chaussons
les assureurs disait que c'était
l'arrêté qui faisait que les choses
n'avançaient pas maintenant que l'arrêté
en place et tenter d'assurer la prise en
main est trop quand même intéressant et
là aussi il faut vraiment être derrière
et comme je les dis je le répète à
chaque fois que je rencontre les
sinistrés que je suis je suis à leurs
côtés s'il faut intervenir en temps vous
êtes vous vous y est très engagé bien
sûr et ils le savent
ce lundi la reconstruction de l'hôpital
de trinité un vin très prégnant la grève
continue demain nous recevons d'ailleurs
serge harry bouquin général de l'ugtm
très bien pour en parler et plus
globalement de la situation des hôpitaux
publics en martinique vous la députée
corinne que vous êtes menacé bakel la
capitale de trinité et sur à trinité
dans sur la circonscription de ma
collègue josette manin
mais c'est le bassin de population du
nord qui est concerné donc c'est voilà
six cent mille habitants avec des
pathologies avec une situation
différente avec un contexte différent et
il est important pour moi d'être aux
côtés de l'ugtm sur ce dossier et je
crois que je les démontrer dès le début
et nous continuons aujourd'hui encore
pas aujourd'hui mais tous les lundis je
fais le point avec eux et nous avançons
petit à petit et vraiment je ne lâcherai
pas je ne lâcherai rien
ni auprès d' du directeur du chu ni
auprès de 2 du gouvernement parce qu'il
faut absolument que que les ministres
verront comprennent qu'il faut qu'ils
investissent sur l'hôpital en martinique
et nous attendons d'ailleurs puisque
nous avons une une réunion
interministérielle outre-mer et santé il
avait promis une réponse d'ici deux
semaines nous sommes à la troisième
semaine et une relance est fait est fait
à l'arrestation que vos paroles n'ont
pas de poids auprès de deux ministères
des oui c'est vrai que nous ne sommes
pas ne sommes pas au parti de monsieur
emmanuel macron donc peut-être que c'est
pour cela que nous sommes pénalisés mais
vous savez que si vraiment une entente
de pages pense qu'encore une fois le
peuple va devoir se saouler parce que la
santé c'est pas une affaire politique
c'est l' affaire de tous pour conclure
vous avez officiellement déclarer votre
engagement aux côtés de pays a lors de
la rentrée de ce parti de lyon va
terminer là dessus en perspective des
élections à la ctm vous vous souhaitez
être candidate vous souhaitez intégrer
la collectivité territoriale navré
nécessairement mon engagement et ma
montre et d'un côté de jean philippe
miller et de marcelin nadeau dans le
cadre de cette bataille pour la ctm
n'est pas du tout aux conditionnée par
un positionnement sur la liste cela ne
veut pas dire que que je pourrai
réfléchira et et changer d'avis mais dès
le départ j'ai dit à jean philippe jeu
je vous donne un coup de main
parce que je considère qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez ils ont mûri jean philippe
amyot guijon philippaerts a vraiment
avec marcellin nadeau une vision
avec eux on va dire une approche
différente de ce que nous avons déjà
ubu est mis en exergue six en martinique
et je crois qu'il faut aussi donner
cette chance à un renouvellement de la
classe politique avec vous souhaitez
vous en tant qu'élu mais en tant que
citoyenne martiniquaise vient changement
bien entendu oui je les dis et je le
répète et je m'assume j'assume j'assume
mes mots et voilà il faut un
renouvellement un renouvellement de la
classe politique avec une dynamique
nouvelle avec un challenge nouveau avec
parce qu'en fait ils ont rang
l'obligation de mieux faire donc pour le
bien de la population
merci manu lac et clermont désir d'avoir
répondu à nos questions bonne journée
bonne semaine